i asked this name and i said
i said um i said man while you was
like pimping like full-fledged pimping
man like how did you like
like lock in so heavy on your craft man
and keep your wraps cause you stopped
he stopped pimping after the first album
and all that [ __ ] right you know what
i'm saying
so um he looked at me but i'm
like i got to say if i didn't have
shay's on bro i
i would have folded i'm talking about he
looked at me so cold like he was looking
through me
right john am i lying bro that
[ __ ] he said just like this
you're not a walking two bubble gum at
the same time
i laugh like that right he didn't say
nothing he just kept looking at me
well all right then all right then all
right oh [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is for real man
he wasn't playing bro he like he's
stared
through me and he said that it's so
funny because i like i'll be in the car
like with my wife and i'll be listening
to sugar free sometimes and she'll be
so like what the [ __ ] are you listening
to
what is this guy saying like it's crazy
because like it's unfortunate like
like sugarfree couldn't exist in 2021 i
don't know he'd get [ __ ] cancelled
man man
mom they'd be like what about my ex
she knew like she got in my car she had
the sugar free i'm not [ __ ] with you
i used to cut that [ __ ] on let her know
like i'm not
that's great that's how you put somebody
under conviction you got that free on
man yeah throw that sugar free on like
listen listen man